on aurait pu choisir en fait un
opérateur autre si on avait fait en fait
qu une mise en concurrence une main un
appel d'offres ce qui n'a pas été le cas
et c'est ce qui manque à l'heure
actuelle est donc un groupement européen
peut être plusieurs opérateurs pour être
tout à fait répondre à une offre et
c'est trop 1,5 de dire toujours aux
opérateurs européens
vous ne pouvez pas être de nouveaux
entrants sur le marché on a déjà les
sociétés américaines et de ne jamais
leur donner la chance
il s'agit en fait du service public de
la santé il s'agit de données
particulièrement sensible cela devrait
être traitée par des opérateurs qui sont
de profits ans et ne pas pouvoir être
soumis à un état étranger
c'est une conception que je développe
aujourd'hui et qui est fréquemment en
fait mis en avant par de nombreux
spécialistes du droit des données ou par
des chercheurs qui sont au fait des
scientifiques inquiets
à l'heure actuelle on a toute la
structure nécessaire et bien évidemment
ces opérateurs qui travaillent déjà bien
ovh est par exemple leaders européens il
pourrait sans doute avec d'autres ou
peut-être seul développer ses
infrastructures pour être capable de
répondre à la demande donc fait de la
plateforme des données de santé